welcome
again to the spectators alternative
party conference i'm kate andrews
economics correspondent
and today we're going to be discussing
rebuilding britain
how we merge the green agenda with our
recovery
from covid19 this panel is kindly
sponsored by
siemens and there are a lot of questions
that we have to answer
the pandemic has brought the british
economy to its knees
businesses are facing a huge amount of
uncertainty an unemployment crisis
looms and the economy is a tenth smaller
still than it was
at the start of the year to tackle all
of this we're going to need bold
new ideas not just to kick-start the
economy but also to incorporate
britain's new sustainability goals some
of which we've just recently heard about
as the prime minister announced a
10-point plan for
what he dubs a green industrial
revolution
but will this be enough and how does the
uk
continue to pursue its sustainability
goals while also recovering
quickly from this pandemic so to discuss
all of this some more we have a
fantastic
panel for you we're joined by rachel
mclean mp transport minister
will wilson chief executive officer of
siemens
mobility limited isabel debrin global
transport leader for
era and lindsay mcquade chief executive
officer for scottish power renewables so
thank you to the whole panel for joining
me
um i'm going to start with opening
remarks just a few minutes from each of
you and then we'll get straight into
questions so rachel i'll start with you
thanks a lot kate and it's absolutely
brilliant to be with you today
and what a great day to be doing this so
i am the minister for transport
decarbonisation
and the future of transport and i think
today is a combination of a huge amount
of work that we have put into
um announcing this 10-point plan that
the prime minister announced today
and as we speak he is holding a round
table virtually of course
uh with a number of leaders uh from
business and all sectors of the economy
in how will this 10 point plan help us
to
build back better and as i see it what
it's doing is setting out a green print
for a green recovery certainly for
the transport system which is the bit
that i'm
most closely involved in and responsible
for decarbonizing which as you will know
is one of the worst emitting sectors and
it doesn't actually show any sign of
reducing its emissions at the moment
this is why we need to take bold and
urgent action
um i'm sure by now that you all know
what's in the ten point plan but if i
can just
highlight a couple of points if that's
okay in in just in a minute
so we envisage this as actually
mobilizing
12 billion pounds of government
investment which is a stimulus for a
further private sector
investment to come in and we see that as
a spur to create and support up to a
quarter of a million
highly skilled green jobs in the uk um
and what's important about this is this
is part of our uniting and leveling up
agenda because we will be able to invest
and recharge areas of the country which
have been left behind
with some of these new technologies and
i would highlight in particular
um the use of hydrogen the investment
into carbon capture and storage
uh offshore wind new nuclear and
of course uh great investments into zero
emission
aviation commercial aviation that does
not harm the planet
um so i'm looking forward very much the
discussion i hope to get into some
q a later on and uh over back to you
again kate thanks rachel over to you
will
thank you for having us here it's it's
really as rachel says
a very exciting day with the
announcements that came out last night
um you know we are focused on the
decarbonization of transport
particularly around promoting public
transportation and getting people out of
their private vehicles
hydrogen has to be a key factor moving
forwards
um along with the offshore uh wind
generation uh for
green energy and green power uh but as
we look at our transportation sector
that we deal with this
um seems mobility around trains and
around the control of
um the the traffic within conabations as
well as
road charging it all fits together very
firmly into what the government's
objectives
have been set out so i think it's a
really exciting um
time for us coming in the leveling up
agenda is
clearly going to benefit from um
the push to departmenization the push to
having
um a transport policy that
is green and one that we can actually
really act upon
what we've seen for the past few years
up until covert is
a lot of groundwork being put in but i
think to rachel's point that
nothing really totally quantifiable but
you could say is
making our transport industry green as
we stand today and i think this is our
opportunity
and i'm hoping that last night's
announcement is really the catalyst for
that so
great timing thanks kate thanks will and
over to you lindsay
thank you kate and uh thanks for asking
me to join you all this afternoon
i as others have said quite an exciting
day for all of us
um but i think what's been really
important for me
as a member of the scottish power team
is the fact that
we've been on this journey for quite
some time and
we've been uh at the renewables business
for decades now if you like and
uh i'm keen to see us going even further
and that i think
it was really underpinned by the
announcements that have been made today
by the pm
um and the exciting targets that have
been announced as well
and i think for me as the chief
executive of the renewables business
within scottish power
um i'm really looking forward to playing
my part and then giving
the energy and providing the energy and
the the projects that will go into
feeding
a lot of the change that's being talked
about whether that's on the
transportation front or indeed the heat
front when we eventually get to that as
well a bit harder to get to but
absolutely necessary
um you know in the company that we work
in uh covert 19 has affected our
operation to the extent where we've had
to come up with
new ways of doing things new ways of
engaging with our customers
new ways of ensuring that we can
continue to operate our assets and keep
the lights on
and new ways of continuing to construct
our projects in a safer manner as
possible
and throughout this year we've we've
really been working hard to make sure
that we can keep doing all of that and
have commissioned
our largest asset to date so that'll
power over 600 000 homes that's the east
anglia one supported by the contract for
difference mechanism
and and it's things like that
investments like that that we're looking
forward to committing to
over the next 10 years we've just
outlined our plan for the next five
years
uh and very much aligns with a lot of
the objectives that have been talked
about today
and you know where 10 billion pounds is
going to be invested in the uk
uh by iberjola through scottish power
and that's going to be a key part of how
we'll support
the green recovery and our progress
tonight zero
back in june of this year we also
published a ten point plan ten seems to
be the magic number
um and although it was cushioned within
scottish powers remember and our
interests
again and what we've sought to do is set
out a plan that's deliverable
feasible easy steps that we can take and
something that
we believe can act very much as a
stimulus that rachel's talked about
a for private investment coming forward
to make
net zero a reality as we go forward and
i think
that's the important thing for me that
we need to see the partnership between
the private and public sector coming
together to create the right policies
and frameworks to make that investment
happen
so that we can achieve that greener
cleaner future that we're all after
thanks lizzy and isabel thanks very much
and uh thanks for having me
um yeah it's great timing as other
people have said well done kate for
getting the prime minister to make an
announcement on the very day
of this uh recording so that's that's
well done
um i mean similar to what lindsay was
saying there
um we just redid our group strategy at
arab and our entire focus now is on
sustainable development and so for us as
a firm we
hugely welcome the focus that the
government's bringing to this
uh this week and going forward i guess
really just two comments having been
involved in this
sort of area this arena for for probably
almost two decades
now in transport um i i think the first
point is that we still haven't quite
connected our industrial strategy
and our policy and i think that's an
issue around the world and this is the
first time that i think we're starting
to see that coming together
so we talk about green jobs and then we
talk about electric buses but how do we
actually
bring cities as procurers as policy
makers together with the creation of
jobs
all across the country in a much more
purposeful and focused way and so i
think if you look at the challenge that
you've set out for this discussion
that's something that we need to
continue to bring ever more
closely together and the other point
really is that we've got to move out of
writing reports on things and into doing
things
at scale and lindsay were just talking
about that there
i think as industry across the piece
but for the private sector in particular
it's up to us also to be very proactive
and come forward to government with
our ideas about how we can do that
including going forward with new
delivery models because
i think the old way of doing things is
fine and we shouldn't stop doing that
but we want to augment that with new
approaches to how we deliver because for
sure it's true that the old approaches
haven't delivered
change at the scale and pace that we
want to see
and that's not because the technologies
aren't there in many cases they are
available
many of them are affordable and so it's
the delivery mechanism and the how
that needs to be our total focus i think
across you know public private
all levels of government um and and sort
of you know geographic
uh scales so we need to kind of not be
reinventing the wheel
let's leverage what we've done in this
country what other people have done
we've just done a big piece of work with
new zealand on hydrogen
um a hydrogen plant for the whole
country um in this country
for the last couple of years we've been
a bit like hydrogen really is it serious
you know so we need to kind of get
ourselves like much more firmly into
that
spot today's announcement helps with
that and kind of bring
the creativity rather than on the should
we have technology x or y
bring all of our focus and creativity
into the the how
and the mechanisms we're going to use to
deliver large-scale roll-ups
thanks so much isabel let's dive into
this 10-point plan
big news uh being recorded this week
about the government's strategy for what
it calls a green industrial revolution
and rachel i'll
come to you first the prime minister has
made some pretty big
pledges to have enough offshore wind
capacity by 2030
to power every home 500 million pounds
for
investment in hydrogen 2.8 billion
pounds for investment in electric cars
creating charging points and the rest
the package adds up to being roughly 12
billion pounds worth of
spending commitments but let's be honest
it still doesn't get us to net zero
and one of the major questions people
are asking about this 10 point strategy
is what in it could actually guarantee
that what the government has put into
law
will come to fruition so do you agree
with the arguments that perhaps despite
having 10 points
it still lacks in the uk's direction as
to how we meet that target
we're seeing here is a world-leading uh
green print as i said in my opening
remarks about how we are going to get to
net zero because you'll remember that we
legislated for net zero
i think it was the year before last now
but it was it at that point we
it's right to say we didn't know how we
were going to get there exactly
although we had some very uh clear
visions that we
we all signed up to we we knew it would
mean large-scale decarbonisation of our
economy across all these hard to
decarbonize
uh areas and sectors and since then we
have been
uh working in a lot of detail across
government to look at
actually what are the mechanics by which
this would happen
um and you you'll probably be aware that
there is a sort of cross government very
high level
group called the climate action
implementation committee that is chaired
by adult sharma that looks at
the carbon budgets in detail and where
we're at on there and what is the gap
between where we are
now where we need to get to and and i
accept that right now
that trajectory is very challenging
specifically uh if you look further out
we we look at this as a down payment on
our carbon budgets
we we know that there is a lot more work
to do but there is detail
in this plan and we will see more detail
coming out on the back of the
spending review which is also happening
at the moment which will uh
lock down the actual cash um and
the different projects and initiatives
that will turn this into
reality and when that happens there will
be those discussions
but with ministers including myself
other ministers across government
we will then be reaching out to the
stakeholders for example the people on
this call and many many others
about what does that mean in your
industry um
and if i just take one example for
example you know the electric vehicle
side of things which i which i know
really well i mean we
we do know how many um
uh jobs we think this is going to create
we actually think this is going to
create 169
000 jobs um across the piece with all
the work that we're doing
um in that so there's a lot more work to
do but this is the start of a very very
ambitious and if i i think it's a world
leading
process isabelle you previously worked
with the prime minister in
city hall and you work towards plans to
lower carbon emissions
in london where i'm sitting now uh
you'll have had a good idea of what he
was thinking
when looking at this 10-point plan when
thinking ahead
on the green agenda do you think that
it's very well considered or
are you waiting to see more from say the
energy white paper before you make up
your mind
it comes back to the the point about how
we deliver so if you think about i don't
know electric buses as an example
this isn't about paying for every single
electric bus a hundred percent
government giving a handout right it's
about how we use incentives
work together across different combined
authorities cities geographies
and across public and private sector and
use the funding that is available from
government to sort of help to catalyze
change we've seen that with electric
vehicles
the reason that people are buying
electric vehicles is partly because
there's a subsidy from government but
also because they're
attractive cheaper to run etc so this
isn't about
government funding paying for all the
technology it's about government funding
kind of being part of a jigsaw
to catalyze change and in that sense i
think uh you know we're kind of on a
good
trajectory now and i think it's really
for all of us to figure out how we use
that and we haven't figured that out yet
because if you look at the 4000 electric
bus announcement
you know how can we actually leverage
relationships and procurement
for bus fleets across the country to
make the best use of that funding we
haven't quite figured that out yet
as a community it's not anyone's fault
and so that's the kind of focus that i
think we need to bring together if we
can do that right
i think we are very clearly on a good
trajectory already
i want to have a wider discussion about
the private sector's role in this so
we'll definitely come back to that topic
but
first lindsay something that's been
noted is that the 10-point plan
overlooks heat how we heat our homes and
that is thought to be a big obstacle
in our in our path to net zero the fact
that millions of homes
possibly tens of millions of homes in
the uk will have to overhaul
how they're heated and bringing
potentially quite expensive technology
or technology that
isn't up to scratch just yet we're gonna
have to convince
and sway hearts and minds that that is
the right thing to do so
um what do you think that was
intentionally overlooked in this
10-point plan
uh do you think there's still some
outstanding questions perhaps to be
answered here
i think if we look at this and we
consider the trajectory within which we
need to consider net zero dates of 2045
2050 being talked about this is our
first plan
this is the first in a number of plans
and steps that the country is going to
have to take to achieve those targets
and much as we did when we set out
carbon budgets and carbon targets in the
past
we have started with what we know what's
familiar and that's the reason that
we've got the proportion of renewable
generation that we have on the bars
today
we need to do more of that we're now
going to the next sector which is around
transportation
and that's if you like the next easy bit
uh except it's not going to be all that
easy
and there's going to be challenge in
there for sure just as there was for
offshore wind i mean i still remember
sitting in meetings
and it being taught we're going to get
to 100 pounds a megawatt hour and the
sharp intake of breath that would then
follow
we're miles past that night we've done
that checking the box move on
innovation is always happening in our
sector and i can see that happening so
you're talking about cost points you're
talking about
you know what's still in the technology
gambit to be proven and explored
that we don't know all the answers today
none of us have got all the answers
today
nobody's got that magic crystal ball but
it doesn't mean that we stop
it doesn't mean that we sit and we wait
for that to happen and we have to wait
until we've got all the answers there
we need to keep going with what we know
quick keep going with what we know can
be deployed
keep tapping into that private
investment keep keep creating those
mechanisms to bring that investment
forward
keep moving on that trajectory and the
heat will follow absolutely
and whether you know and clearly there's
there's options around electrification
of heat as well
and there will be change but all of this
journey has been a change um if you
change the the public awareness and
consciousness as to where
their electricity sources are now you
speak to them and and
and i laugh and say the best advert i
have is that my technology is highly
visible wind farms are seen
people understand where generation comes
from kids understand where generation
comes from i don't think i had a grasp
of where electricity came from when i
was
you know age five that's the best advert
we have people now care
about where their electricity comes from
and they're going to care very quickly
about what fuel is powering their car
and very soon thereafter we will care
about what fuel is heating their home
it's a journey that we're
all on we don't have to have all the
answers and everything in place by 2030
but we will i have no doubt between now
and then
have a much clearer idea about what the
heat issue is going to be
and what the scale of the issue is and
what technologies are going to help
solve that issue well
offshore wind has been a huge success
story here in the uk
but in this process we know that some
technologies and innovations will
succeed and and others will
fail are we being honest enough about
the difficult choices that are
ahead of us when it comes to
decarbonization the idea of
decarbonizing the economy is a
huge one and one that is going to
require some sacrifice
interesting question but i think perhaps
we are slightly beating ourselves up
a little bit harder than we really need
to as lindsay was saying we have come a
long way
i mean let's go back 15 years ago coal
fire power
generation was absolutely critical to
what we wanted nobody really wanted
nuclear
we've redressed that we've got offshore
wind we've got nuclear coming in
these are deemed as green they're deemed
as being safe
uh bearings moving forwards the
committee on climate change has
indicated that
you know by utilizing hydrogen whether
it's in energy industry
or transportation mobility it's the
difference between the 80
that we've got today and the 100
decarbonization
and i think you know the government
declaring this this agenda
um and then passing it back to uh you
know the various sectors that
um are pushing forwards for it combined
with um
you know i assume a good energy white
paper to be released next
next week hopefully um it gives us the
basis
what we really need to see is is the
catalyst to actually allow this to
happen
um you know as lindsay said getting the
right
price for the green generated
electricity seemed a huge hurdle just
a number of years ago it's exactly the
same with the price of hydrogen we need
to see
the green generation of hydrogen um but
also then
the right mechanism so that actually can
be sold competitively and bring the
price down
which will then influence people into
coming forwards
and i think finally you know private uh
partnership
is one way of moving forward there's a
lot of um money that
we as a company we as an industry would
be very willing to invest
in driving these green solutions
forwards and that mustn't be overlooked
and you know we've got the agenda
now we actually need the environment
whereby we can accelerate this in order
to hit
the 30 35 40 45 or 50
uh target whichever one um we're
actually aiming towards
rachel you mentioned some of the jobs
that the government is hoping will be
created through its green energy schemes
and i guess this starts to get to the
heart of this panel today the really big
question
the government does not want to
prioritize the covert recovery or the
green revolution over the other they
want to do both
at the same time and that's one of the
reasons that this 10 point plan was
announced today it is in the wake
of coba 19 it is hopeful that it will be
part of the recovery
how realistic do you really think it is
that one won't have to take priority
over the other
when we consider that a lot of the
economic pain
still hasn't come yet it's estimated
that unemployment will peak
next summer it's not going to peak this
year more people are going to be losing
their jobs
are you or the government concerned that
at some point pressure is going to come
down
just to get the economy moving
regardless of which way it starts moving
putting the green energy agenda aside
okay i think that's even more uh reason
why we have to put rocket boosters uh
zero emission ones under behind this
plan
precisely because of what you've said we
do need to
put the power of government on an
unprecedented scale as we've seen
throughout the pandemic
with the amount of taxpayers money
that we have put into protecting public
health and keeping the economy going
supporting jobs and businesses just as
we've done that
throughout the pandemic as we look
forward to god willing and touch wood
and
everything coming out of this eventually
with the vaccines that are coming
that is when we will need to step in on
an unprecedented scale to support the
economy going forward because
we do not want to see people who have
lost their jobs and perhaps are in
industries that will
with the best will in the world not be
able to come back very soon
we don't want to see those people
forgotten and left behind which is why
there's such a focus on jobs and
reskilling it does provide that
hope for people that they will be able
to get that retraining that support to
get into a new industry
and when they've acquired those skills
there will be work for them
and there will be work for them in the
places where they live and that
that is at the heart of what we're doing
um as you know as a compassionate
conservative government
looking at this leveling up agenda and
for me that's what leveling up
absolutely is where the market has
done so much but it can only go so far
that's when we need to come in to
provide that extra layer of security
and when we've done that the market will
then come in again
because it can see that certainty it
will benefit from that multiplier effect
so i do not at all accept the fact that
this isn't either or
these two things are completely
intertwined
and just to follow up on that point
quickly
we've been told that the huge amounts of
taxpayer money that have been spent this
year are a one-off
spend and it's not obvious that in the
coming years the bank of england say
will
keep printing money if it's to fund
day-to-day spending they've been very
clear that
the money that they've been using to
prop up the treasury is very
covet specific if the government does
have to make hard choices if it has to
start prioritizing certain spending of
their over other projects is it prepared
to put
the green agenda at the top of that list
and perhaps put other things like
education or defense
lower down the list in order to afford
it
i think you're sort of tempting me kate
to go into areas which are really
for the chancellor and of course i don't
envy him
those hard choices uh these sort of
fiscal
matters are really uh for the for the
treasury
but look you know if i can come back to
what we're doing now we are in the
middle of a global
pandemic we have had to support
everybody in the country pretty much has
had some kind of support from the
government
in some shape or form um and we will
continue
to do that and and we the the mechanism
by which we will do that
is through the government support to
some of these innovative industries
which will
in turn then grow and generate and
create jobs
so that is how i see it and that is
firmly at the heart of the prime
minister's vision for this country
lindsay i think it's fairly safe to say
that if the covet pandemic had not hit
the world as it did
that the green agenda would have been
what we would have been discussing for
much of this year it probably would have
dominated
the political agenda obviously that
hasn't been the case but this government
is now
trying to to bring it back and
prioritize it um
on rachel's comments about confidence do
you think given everything that's
happened that businesses still feel
confident
in investing in these technologies do
you think enough has been done to signal
that they are the waves of the future
from my perspective
covert 19 has been something that this
time last year none of us could have
reasonably foreseen
and we've all taken huge strides to um
ensure certainly within the energy
sector that we can continue to
provide service to our customers
continue to generally continue to
provide reliable power connections to
our grid systems etc
um but i think the one thing that it
really has allowed is a period of
reflection
almost as well to say if we're going to
come out of this we need to come out of
it in the right way
um and so the bill might better you know
freeze and everything else that
we've been talking about is absolutely
the path that we should be on we would
have been
in the midst of cop 26 right now had
that had had that's not happened
hopefully all going well we'll be back
here
in 2021 having those further discussions
but
having had that pause and in terms of
confidence
my business hasn't stopped and i'm aware
that the global business that i'm part
of hasn't stopped either so
i think in terms of appetite and desire
to move on
we're continuing to move in that way
we've announced acquisitions
scattered throughout the globe and
offshore we've announced acquisitions
and onshore
and pretty much in almost every
continent we've talked about
our scale of ambition and our drawing
for clean energy across
across the globe um and i think that
that is going to continue
we recently held our market stay where
we briefed
uh everybody about our plans for the the
next five years
that's a demonstration of our confidence
we wouldn't be out there committing
uh and talking about our investment
plans if we didn't have that confidence
because what we know we're doing is on
the right path
now i think the responsibility we have
as somebody who does this day in day out
it's you know almost second nature to us
we need to ensure that we're bringing
everyone else with us we need to share
that story we need to communicate that
effectively and also talk about
what the world's going to look like once
that investment happens
um and and try and bring everyone on
that journey with us and
and with that will come a broader set of
confidence um
and a support for for the plans that are
being announced
by not just us but by everyone else as
well and commitment will follow
will do you at siemens echo
lindsay's confidence and thinking
forward to next year when cop 26
hopefully does take place
in glasgow in november is it realistic
to think that we'll be in a position to
solely focus
on green energy uh it looks like going
into 21 with updates about the vaccine
uh comments that we may still be social
distancing well through the year
uh that the green agenda really will be
at the back at the top of the list
the green agenda has to be at the top of
the list because you know in the short
term
it is an economic stimulus it can be
used for leveling up
as rachel pointed out you know it
doesn't matter where
people are actually creating jobs in
which areas provided it's
towards the green agenda but i think one
of the things
we've got to think about and perhaps
again we should just look backwards
lindsay would be very familiar with your
short
um win generation market
and if we go back to where that started
you know government
undertook to fund one or two key
projects
and i think that this is what we've got
to repeat in order to move forward and
once those key projects were up and
running we had the concept we proved the
concept
we proved the distribution all of a
sudden the industry
absolutely boomed uh to what we see
today with the biggest offshore
wind farms that we have anywhere in the
world um here in the in the shores of
the united kingdom
and i don't see any reason why we can't
do the same with the other
elements of this green agenda
particularly around hydrogen where we
are world leaders in some of the
hydrogen technologies
we have already if you take a city like
aberdeen got
trials underway so we just need to
really get that catalyst for the
distribution get
the uh the private sector willing to
actually invest
in what is required in order to meet you
know what the government's objective is
but also what
what the uk needs in order to become
carbon neutral
uh moving forward so i think we've got
huge opportunity here i think it's
totally possible
um and i think with three quarters of
the way in having the right
framework for us to actually springboard
forwards
as we have done in other sectors already
isabel you previously worked with the
prime minister in
city hall you work towards uh take
you work towards a lowering carbon
output in
london you'll have an idea of how the
prime minister was thinking
when putting forward this template plan
how well considered do you think the
plan is or are you waiting to
make that decision until you see a more
comprehensive
white paper that's actually supposed to
lay out a broad pathway
to 2050 you know waiting to see
anything i think i just kind of want to
side with lindsay on the point about you
know
you just can't live your life like that
and especially if you're trying to make
change and make new things happen you've
got to just continue moving down the
road
and it is a serious point because i
think there is often this sort of
i'll wait to see the 200-page plan and
then i'll decide what i'm gonna do
and unless we're all kind of moving
forward then you know nothing's gonna
happen and no 200 page plan is going to
solve that anyway
um so so we've all got an obligation to
continue to play a really proactive role
in moving these things
these things forward i mean i think our
experience in london was you know
it's good to have some really blue sky
creative
thinking and challenge things and i
think hydrogen is a great example where
you know
i was certainly in the transport
industry five six years ago
you know hydrogen was kind of like never
going to be affordable never going to be
a serious thing there were always those
few people who were championing it and
everyone would sort of roll their eyes
and oh there they go again
um and you know that's moved along
massively i think we all recognize
what some of the challenges are with
hydrogen but everyone's starting to say
oh hang on and especially if we think
across sector rather than thinking
you know transport should do this and
energy is going to do that
but if we can have a kind of
multi-sectoral response to it
i think we can we can come up with some
really brilliant and we're involved in
various schemes around this country and
also around the world
that are starting to bring those new
approaches that that william was talking
about earlier
um in so so it's having that kind of
boldness and
the creativity and then it's also just
about like grinding out you know the lar
the scaling up of what we already have
and that was something that we did with
hybrid buses we brought in the electric
buses look at what's happened with cycle
lanes that was all like new
infrastructure that we brought in
um so you know there is something about
just rolling out what you already have
and certainly that was you know the
eight years that
i worked with boris at city hall we did
a lot of that work in the transport
sector for sure
well let's stick on transport rachel uh
and isabelle makes a few interesting
points there including the fact that
technology that a few years back people
would have said
that's behind the sky thinking has
actually come online and that's very
often because
private companies you know they pour
investment into this technology
uh they really push forward with it and
something comes through you have those
breakthrough moments so in transport
specifically but also if you can speak a
bit more broadly
uh to to the uk in the coming years uh
what
is that what should that relationship
between the public sector and the
private sector
look like not simply in terms of
developing these technologies but also
potentially
paying for them because at the end of
the day if the taxpayer has to foot
the whole bill that's going to be
extremely expensive you're going to need
to see
uh private companies investing as they
have been doing as well
absolutely i think it's a really
interesting um
piece of work that we do in government
so um
most of the people on the call will know
that we have regular dialogue with
um stakeholders across i hate that word
but it's it's just the word that we use
people who run businesses basically or
who've got interest
in policy so i spend a lot of time
talking to isabel and other people
about what they think the government
should be doing where should the
government be putting its support and
backing and taxpayers money and where is
the private sector best place to come in
and from those discussions which are
very granular we will then formulate
a policy and that's when we will start
to assemble that into if you like an ask
to go to uh treasury and say this is
where we think this is a business case
effectively
if we this is what industry has told us
if we invest x amount into hydrogen
let's take that as an example
that will then stimulate um the academic
research to be done it will stimulate
those business cases of those other
investors to come in
so that works happening all the time and
and it is really important that we
always
consider where is government best place
to spend
that precious resource i think one area
where we
ought to focus and we do focus very much
is on the r d
side because we know that if we can
invest in those very sort of emerging
uh technologies that are not
commercialized at the moment and perhaps
a long way
from that and and actually many of those
will fail but it is still right that we
take the view at that very early stage
innovation
out of even just one of those out of a
basket of a hundred perhaps ideas
one of those could be a real game
changer in something like uh green
hydrogen or
or a battery technology for example just
to take two there are many more
and that is i think that r d approach
that and backing those innovators and
those really small businesses
um who have got the best minds in in the
world often
especially in the uk we've got a
fantastically
exciting scene there that is i think how
we
will take this forward it really is a
partnership
and it it's really exciting to be
involved in it
uh well there's been talk in the past
about
industry's responsibility to make the
planet greener
much more recently their responsibility
to help us get to
net zero but now there's increasing talk
about industry's responsibility and
recovering from the copic crisis
um how do you see the role of business
in this recovery and to what extent
should that burden be on businesses
shoulders
as the government as much as the
government's less than
what how do you see that being a major
employer
and also being an industry an industry
leader that develops technology
we can't change our strategy because of
covert tobit undoubtedly has had a major
effect on what we're doing
but our strategy was set over a number
of years our r d
cycle takes you know 10 years to develop
new products
longer in certain areas particularly
sort of
the generation of hydrogen um and
you know in a transportable form using
ammonia which is one of our
real developments going on at the moment
combined with you know the development
offshore
uh wind farms and all the turbines that
we've done with siemens
mesa these are really long-term
strategies so
i viewed covid undoubtedly we have to
support
britain we have to support the people in
the leveling up we have to make sure
that we
create an even balance in order to get
the economy kick started
but in terms of my view of where this
my company's going and where the
industry is going it's unchanged
you know it's going to take far more
than
the last three months when we've
actually come to understand what kobe
means to us
to make us change from the taxes we got
we've been talking about decarbonization
for a very long time
um we've had the target of 2050 for a
number of years now we've had extra
targets of 45 and 40
put in place of transportation the
scottish being even more aggressive
and those still remain the expectation
is still
we will deliver those i think in three
or four years time we'll look back and
covert would be a nasty blossom
you know in the past but we will be back
concentrating on
you know what is really going to help
society in the longer term
and you know the advent of a vaccine in
such a short space of time i think sort
of is an illustration how
the industry or industry particularly
the medical industry has reacted
and that will be the catalyst to getting
us back to where we were before
isabel i'll ask you to follow up on that
to what extent is industry responsible
not just for making this planet greener
but also for recovering from the covert
crisis
for it depends on who we are you know
you can kind of lump all of the private
sector into one category we're all very
different and this calls one example of
that
i think for us you know the role that
we're particularly obviously we're
designing buildings we're designing
infrastructure so we have a role there
but that will be very different from
lindsey israel william's role etc
um and as employers we have a
responsibility we employ 16 000 people
worldwide but but i think where i'm
increasingly seeing our role as a sort
of engineering consultancy is as
integrators and bringing people together
so how can we kind of create projects
and partnerships
and bring those forward to government is
a really exciting place where because
we're operating
across and between a lot of different
entities and sometimes we don't have a
particular vested interest in either
direction we're just kind of interested
in pulling the parties together so
so i think there's more and more need
for that um as we
move forward the other thing i was just
going to say was i think you know we
don't want to set
up covet always not that you're doing
this but you know as a kind of competing
with the green
agenda certainly in transport there's
some really interesting ways in which
covet is actually
accelerating some trends that
pre-existed
covet so in the urban transit arena we
already were seeing a major
cannibalization of public transport
revenue
because of the rise of active travel and
the rise of
other providers whether that's
e-scooters whether that's uber
and therefore the kind of traditional
public transport model
which is all designed to you know help
our cities function greenly and get
people out of their cars
was creaking under those pressures now
kovat has sort of you know collapsed the
whole thing
temporarily but there's an opportunity
therefore to rebuild
the urban transport business model and
revenue model in quite a different
creative way and you know um saw the
chancellor talking about
national road pricing the other day you
know these are the kinds of
conversations that maybe we wouldn't be
having
if it weren't for kova leading us to
really question a lot of things about
things that we kind of didn't want to
talk about before and now we kind of
have to talk about them they're forced
out into the open
so i do think there's a real opportunity
to actually use the code crisis however
difficult and frustrating and awful it's
been for all of us to catalyze some
change
that's going to be really positive
certainly in my industry and others as
well
i want to come to lindsay on the
investment climate but
very quickly isabel uh your comments
have prompted a question for
rachel i think because as isabel notes a
lot has
changed since the curved crisis and the
vaccine may take us back to normal in
many ways
but certain trends like working from
home are probably here to stay
for a lot of companies anyway the prime
minister makes a lot about investment
and infrastructure and what he wants to
build up but it may well be the case
that postcovid
not all of that is needed do you think
in transport
more widely the government is is ready
to change its manifesto commitments
where the policies that it thought it
would bring in
pre-covered now seeing where the demand
really is and perhaps that means that
actually they move away from
infrastructure
and more into other kinds of green
energy technology but again difficult
decisions that
the government's going to have to make
in the next few months and years
absolutely and i think this is a live
discussion isn't it with all of us
um including people on the panel i mean
look a lot of the infrastructure that we
have
were actually elected on in our
manifesto i would point to
a couple of things and we are delivering
on that for example hs2 is controversial
but we took a decision on that and
actually industries broadly welcomed
that
um and these are big projects that we
have been talking about for many many
years and the view was
you know let's take this decision and
let's build this because it is
is essential uh for uniting our country
and
and connecting some of these places that
are further away and also for
modernizing our entire public transport
system
and again with roads as well we we are
putting a lot of investment in
into roads because yes things will
change
but we need to make the roads that we've
already got much better and that's what
the road building program is about and
again these things are often with these
really seismic changes
um you think that it's going to happen
overnight and
it doesn't happen overnight it's a
gradual evolution we'll we'll look back
in 10 or 20 years time
and we'll see a huge change but on a day
by day basis
think things will sort of look uh
quite similar i think in in many ways
yes we have people working from home but
anyone that's walked around london in
this latest lockdown will see there are
a lot of people
still having to work they are still
physically having to go to places
to deliver services that can't be
delivered remotely
so upgrading what we've got making sure
it's efficient it's new it works it's
built in
a carbon neutral where utilizing modern
technologies to build it in
a much faster way and not get bogged
down
this is really really important for for
our agenda and it's something that we're
absolutely focused on in the department
for transport
uh lindsey to come back to you do you
think the climate is right
right now for uh investing in in green
technology and green solutions are the
priorities right are the incentives
right um has the government
got this right and is any of that in the
10-point plan today or do you expect to
see
more in the coming weeks when perhaps we
get a white paper
i'm hoping that there'll be a little
more meat when we see the white paper
and i know that there are a number of
other
consultations and processes running
right now and
i've mentioned allocation round four
this will be the fourth time
the uh the cfd auction process will take
place next year so again a really
positive signal coming out of government
that
they're committing to support and create
that and sustain that framework
i guess what's particularly pleasing for
me is that
the first time since at cfd allocation
room one
we're going to actually have a pot for
established technologies coming back as
well
which makes sense to me because onshore
wind and solar
are also very cheap cost-effective
technologies to be deploying
to help us along that green recovery
process help us
achieve net zero and right now as as the
questions the positions being made
earlier it's not about one versus the
other
we need it all we need to be doing
things in parallel and we can't slow
down that investment so where we've got
technologies that work
we should be deploying them in anger
today and creating the investment models
and frameworks that will bring them on i
think the other important thing for me
is that
that contract for difference mechanism
that or that contract and the auction
style
is now proven it's established it's been
copied by other jurisdictions
and that's the you know the sincerest
form of flattery that you can have
it's got the confidence of investors
people like it and they will invest on
it
despite the fact that you know the
results of that first auction
have seen prices tumbling um and again
that's a reflection of the innovation
the efficiency that's been driven into
those processes and the opportunity
that's there as well the competition has
really resulted in a benefit for
consumers and businesses across the land
that will then benefit for
the knock-on and cheaper energy costs
going through i think
where there is more challenge and where
there's um clearly processes on going to
science around
investing in the infrastructure and the
network that will connect all that green
generation
that's more of a challenge right now um
and clearly there's there's
a process is ongoing i think there's
a need to ensure that the regulatory
framework keeps a pace
with the aspiration with regard to green
recovery and net zero
and again we shouldn't be looking
backwards this is we have to be more
progressive we have to be
forward-looking
we have to ensure that for example the
right
mechanisms are there to ensure that when
somebody does go out and purchase their
first electric vehicle or indeed hire an
electric vehicle
that they have got ready access to a
charge point in the vicinity of where
they live or where they intend to use
that vehicle
and indeed when you're starting to look
at heavy haulage or
a larger larger scale transportation or
transportation into more rural
as a country that they will have access
to the necessary hydrogen equipment that
they need
to make sure that their fleet can run
and we need to make sure that all of
that is there
in advance there's a bit of um future
proofing requirement got to be going on
and and we have to go with those again
those technologies that we know when are
proven so
my view is we almost have the toolkit
that we need
we just need to make sure that we're
using it properly
the opportunity is there an investment
will come
i think the challenges are around making
sure that we don't see that investment
trickle off into other international
markets
the uk currently does have a lead
position when it comes to lead
investing in green energy we should all
want to maintain that it's a great
market to be in
the renewable sector is a great sector
to work in and i fully agree with
everything that's been said about the
opportunity around green jobs green
infrastructure
um and the opportunity that presents the
country coming out of this crisis and
it's not a need at all we just need to
get on with it
uh the last question i'll pose before i
get final remarks from all of you
and starting with you rachel is what do
you think is still the biggest
barrier uh that the uk faces to
implementing
much of this green agenda that has been
announced many have noted that the
government has failed
to reach this year's emission targets uh
if it continues to fail to do so
then 2050 is going to be kicked way down
the road so what do you think the
biggest barrier still is and then i'll
go around the panel and ask everyone
i just think uh there are there are many
uh barriers
frankly are aren't there with it with
the change of this nature
and i think probably uh one of the
challenges as with any area of
government policy where there is a big
change it will be public attitudes and
it will be taking
the public with us my sense is that
industry
are pretty much with us despite and
you've heard that tonight despite
obviously the challenges and
and the want for detail and the call for
you know working handy glove etc
you know we can provide all that i think
that the challenge will be
uh for for members of the public um
because
there is there is a sense sometimes that
this is is a binary choice between
sort of you know possibly debt there i
say it
you know there may be a perception out
there that this is going to make their
lives difficult or more expensive
and i think our job in government is to
say no it's not
um because you know we are expecting
economies of scale and all these things
we're expecting the
the market to to re to really come in we
talked about um offshore wind earlier
and how
at the time it was seen as preposterous
that any of that would deliver
and i think at the outset of some of
these policies they will look very very
ambitious and stretching and challenging
and people will naturally be skeptical
that the government can deliver it
or will have enough charge points all
these details
and i think that will be really where
our our challenge is
to make sure that we've got a
coordinated plan that we can present to
the public
um to answer all those sort of common
sense questions i mean what you know
when i go out into my constituency
at the weekend obviously in a socially
distanced way
um for an essential reason that those
are the sorts of things that people will
say to me well
you know i can't afford an electric car
or i haven't got a charger or what about
when i drive to scotland
i think those will be the the
nitty-gritty of it
and that's obviously what we need to do
as ministers i think that will be
what we'll really will have to wrestle
with
uh will what do you think the biggest
barrier is that
i'm i'm greatly in agreement with what
rachel just said public attitude and
actually
the shift from the current ways of
travel
um to the future ways to travel
you know there's going to be i think
huge resistance to the withdrawal of
petrol and diesel combustion engines
in 10 years or less than 10 years time
2030 but that again is
another catalyst will move in um but i
think that
the other barriers what i've mentioned
already it's about
having the right framework so that you
know
we as private industry uh whether it's
you know
isabelle side of things or my side of
things or indeed you know
wherever it is have the right mechanism
in order to be able to invest to move
things forwards
take down the barriers of bureaucracy
that we sometimes still see in trying to
introduce new technologies
and move forward and i think we can
learn so much from what's happened
in um the power generation market and
renewables in such a short term
you know over the last five years that's
where we have to start and pick up some
of those models
uh working with government um to bring
them into the transportation
whether it's around you know charging of
cars or introduction v highways or
indeed something very close to my heart
the production of hydrogen trains um
here in england in the north of england
which assists with leveling up thanks
will lindsey well i mean
this this isn't a problem that's unique
to the uk right you know i think
nobody's really cracked this
around the world um but hopefully that's
changing my feeling is that the public
temperature on this is changing even in
the last like 12 to 18 months
and i guess you know rachel will know
much more about this than i do but my
limited experience of politics is that
if you don't have a burning platform and
pressure
you know things don't happen uh the end
you know so we
i worked under ken's administration in
city hall or at tfl
and we were trying to do loads of stuff
because he was really passionate about
climate change
and there just wasn't that appetite and
pressure from the public
and then the air quality thing came up
the agenda massively very effective
lobbying within the city
and we rebadged a lot of what we wanted
to do under the climate change agenda
into air quality under bourse's
administration because that was where
the political heat was
and that was why we were able to achieve
you know a host of things that we
weren't able to achieve previously it
wasn't you know
any magic thing um so i guess you know
maybe we need to be open-minded to
what that pressure point is and what
that burning platform
is and it isn't always what we think it
is or i think it's
going to be um and so what can we tap
into where there's some really natural
momentum just echoing what william and
um
and rachel said there and the other
thing i would say this
i'm not sure this might come across as
slightly weird but if you look
at the last year you know we've seen a
lot of activism as well
black lives matter etc i think in our
professional lives we sometimes think of
ourselves as somehow you know we're
waiting for somebody to tell us to do
something like why can't we bring that
activism and that public pressure into
our own professional lives
and be a bit more you know proactive
brave energetic you know i don't see
enough of that in my
um you know now i'm middle aged i feel
like you know we're all we're all being
a little bit you know
a little bit passive and maybe we need
to kind of bring a little bit more
energy and enthusiasm ourselves
and a bit more burning platform into our
professional lives as well
and lindsay so i would agree with a
number of things everyone else has said
in the panel today and i do think that
there's a degree about public perception
and indeed misconceptions
that continue to rain and i think uh my
job
and others in our sector as well as to
continue to to myth bust
um and have these misconceptions put
back him
back in their place you know we're doing
really exciting things with one
generation we've had a global first
within the last six weeks that we've
black started we've rejected the grid
from wind and that's again something
that
a short number of years ago people
naysayers would have said would never
ever happen
um it's not so much the thing i want to
talk about it's not so much a barrier is
potentially an opportunity what i think
i'm most excited about
is that energy is going to get personal
in the next 10 years it's going to
affect people's homes much more directly
it's going to affect how they choose to
travel much more directly and that to me
is an
opportunity because it means people are
actually going to care
about what's going on when it was just
decarbonization of the
electricity sector they can't tell what
color the electrons are that they're
using to
you know power their kettle charge their
phone whatever whatever nobody really
bothers it was they were passive
now they're going to care and i think
that that is an equal amount of
opportunity as it is
a barrier and i think that everyone in
this call and the wider sector should
embrace that
and we really have a responsibility to
help consumers along that journey help
the electorate along that journey and
take them with it so that you know there
are people
who this is day in day out what we do um
but trying to explain that to everybody
else but
the benefits that that's going to have
um is also the biggest opportunity that
we we can all have
thanks lindsay and isabel thanks very
much kaden and thanks again for
organizing this it's been great to hear
everyone's uh views
i mean i'm not sure how much there is to
add i guess i just pick up the point
that you mentioned earlier but
use the word sacrifices you know there's
sort of this fear that we have to make
sacrifices to deliver
a green economy green jobs green
outcomes um
and i think we're too afraid of that um
you know and therefore we're quite
tentative in approaching some of these
issues
um whereas if you kind of thought about
you know the benefits that people are
going to get and build it around you
know what is the user experience i'm
trying to deliver lindsey was talking
about that earlier
and how do we kind of almost work
backwards from that um
certainly in the transport sector we we
are often quite afraid of talking to our
users because we're you know used to
being
beaten up about you know everything
going wrong um and actually if you start
from the user
and find a way that you can design
something that they're going to love
even a national road pricing scheme
could be designed in a way that people
will be better off than they are today
like it better than what they've got
today and
and embrace it and so that political
fear you know we need to just sort of
over
political small pay here we just need to
overcome that and
and almost start from the premise of
like people are going to love this so
how do we design it in a way that people
will love it and embrace it
and really bring that into the heart of
our thinking and i think we can deliver
you know on all that positive energy and
change that we all want to see
thank you so much isabel and thanks to
our whole panel
isabel lindsay will and rachel for your
fascinating contributions
thanks again to siemens for sponsoring
this panel
and a big thanks to our audience for
watching i know you'd like to be
thanking our panel in the usual way
i'll assume you're clapping at home if
you do want
to watch more from spectator tv and from
alternative party conference you can do
so for free
on our website tv.spectator.co.uk
thanks again